alright guys what's up how's it going
hey what's up hello hello alright anyway
let's get on with the video
I really want to get more Instagram
followers so why don't you guys follow
me that's the whole video it's just it's
just a little vlog of me asking you guys
to follow me no for real everyone want
to get more Instagram followers right
now I have about 8,000 on my Instagram
page which may seem like a lot but
compared to other social media people
who have millions and millions and
millions and millions and millions of
followers it really isn't that much so
I've been doing some research and it
seems like what's really popular on
Instagram right now is body painting
which is basically just female models
getting painted and clothes and it looks
like they're dressed but they're
actually naked so all I have to do is
get one of these accounts to use me as
their model I spent the next few hours
trying to contact every single body
painting Instagram page I could find
guys Jenn the body painter who gets
millions and millions of views on each
one of her posts just agreed to use me
as her model I'm super excited to do
this I hope I get a bunch of followers
out of this let's go hey how's it going
good good good is there anything I can
do to prepare for this wax the whole
body do it for the Instagram followers
so I'm heading downtown to get a sugar
wax sugaring supposed to hurt a lot less
than regular waxing it's just lemon
water and the last ingredient Oh sugar
there we go
so it's not hot you're not gonna get
burnt and they pull in the direction
that your hair grows I don't know why
I'm doing this I got to the salon and I
was really nervous
so was the lady I had a lot of chest
hair and I asked her if maybe I could
have a local anaesthetic or something
she gave me some baby powder
Oh hurts so bad I ended up passing out
when I woke up and look down I realized
I have a 13 year old Bar Mitzvah bot I
took my hairless bod to go buy some very
little underwear because I can't be
naked in the shoes I met Jen the body
painter and her whole family but before
we started shooting I wanted to learn a
little bit about how they got into this
it's them from like using bodies to
advertise it pretty much because when I
got painted as a cheetah I got so much
attention is it very different than
regular painting oh yeah because the
person moves so with like a canvas
you're just gonna sit there for hours
and play your music whatever feel really
relaxed how long does it take you Julia
Captain America with seven to eight
hours for you right now what we're
getting ready to do gonna take us two
and a half hours so you guys are like a
family who does really weird things
together and I would literally come home
from school and as soon as I walk in the
door like our kitchen is in sight so I
would see like topless girls just
walking around like I'm never painted
naked models in my house it's just like
my dad walking around naked anyway time
for me to get naked it was awkward
because I realized I'm I'm at work what
is happening right now we then have to
take a bunch of pictures for the
thumbnail being an instagramer isn't
easy
then they gave me some pre-painted
shorts so they didn't have to paint my
you know looked at their phone to find
pictures of clothes and started painting
[Music]
she also had to paint inside my
bellybutton that was a big no-no
[Music]
that time for the big reveal Oh polish
Wow
oh my god yo it looks so good
Wow if anybody watches friends when
Bruce Willis talks to himself yeah sex
machine I'm a sex machine right now oh I
said that nobody laughed so be good
this painting is insane you did that me
while I was like talking and laughing
yeah yeah great it's time to go out see
if people notice see what people think
so you get ready for naked Eric at first
people didn't even notice and when they
did they didn't know what it was those
leggy yeah leggings that feels like your
skin in your skin
it's my skin wait what oh wait oh my god
it's
are you a little cold it's a bit nipply
in here you're wearing underwear because
there you know know that it's my penis
is taped no no I'm kidding it's not it's
also blizzarding outside so maybe not
the wisest Joystiq not at all I have to
go not stop staring at your penis I am
so sorry Eric I just can't do it look at
my eyes so this is super fun most people
had no idea it took a lot of people a
long time to realize I was painted and
once they realized they were so
impressed with the paint job so I think
that's the coolest thing about this
video was like how good these guys are
at what they do body painting truly is
an art form it's really impressive now
I'm gonna head home figure out how to
wash this off getting home sucked
because there was a blizzard outside and
well paint doesn't really keep you warm
my nipples are so hard right now
showering was fun though I looked like a
human bath bomb it looked pretty cool
I've been in the shower for 45 minutes
and it's still not coming off
and my whole shower is bleached black so
I just finished editing it's been a week
and here's the update Jen the body
painter has posted my post she tagged me
in it currently has over 500,000 views
and my Instagram page I only got 100
followers i waxed my whole body for a
hundred followers I've been itchy all
week for a hundred followers everyone
just cared about the body painters and
not about me I'm not giving up though
I'm gonna keep making these videos till
I get a million followers
[Music]
you